noir de merde [ __ ] [ __ ] des
dizaines de messages racistes
antisémites sexiste posté par des
policiers sur deux groupes facebook et
whatsapp vient d'être révélée par la
presse des commentaires haineux dénoncée
par le ministre de l'intérieur
christophe castaner depuis les années 70
des policiers font régulièrement l'objet
d'accusation de racisme
[Applaudissements]
une des premières dénonciations de
racisme dans la police c'est la sphère
mohamed diab en 1972 cette année là ce
père de famille algérien est tué à bout
portant par un policier au sein même du
commissariat de versailles
selon des témoins présents sur place des
propos racistes ont été tenus à
l'encontre de la victime des
déclarations rapportées par son épouse
au journal télévisé
[Musique]
la personne qui tire a appris le
pistolet mitrailleur et lui de l'altima
de rester sur sa classe mais après c'est
relever leur ai demandé s'ils voulaient
tirer sur lui la personne qui tire à lui
répliqua qu'ouis je vais tirer sale race
en 1981 le policier bénéficie d'un
non-lieu
la légitime défense ayant été retenu en
autre accusation de racisme envers des
policiers à mulhouse cette fois un homme
de 55 ans affirme avoir été tabassé par
quatre policiers après un accident de
voiture
actuellement frappées j'étais traité des
selles chadli sale arabe vaches et veaux
malienne qui se fait chez nous ces
accusations beaucoup de policiers ne s'y
reconnaissent pas comme ici en 1992
quand le policier mal dans sa peau
effectivement ça va générer en lui des
idées qui ne sont pas les siens après à
la saisie des racistes pas forcément
raciste dans le sens où entre une race
mais raciste il est aigri de par la
société les associations dénoncent eux
si les contrôles au faciès en 2009 selon
une étude réalisée en france par une
fondation américaine
un noir aurait 6,2 fois plus de risques
d'être contrôlées qu'un blanc pour un
arabe
la probabilité et 7,7 fois plus élevé de
contrôle malheureusement c'est au faciès
et aussi malheureux vente mal rasé gêne
au basket tu vois tout de suite des
chiffres corroborés par une autre
enquête le nez en 2016 par le défenseur
des droits jacques toubon une étude qui
révèle que les personnes perçues comme
noirs ou arabes ont vingt fois plus de
probabilités d'être contrôlé qu'une
personne blanche
[Musique]